one domino at a time the first one
obviously
you know is making the playoffs and
winning the north and then
there's some other ones to be laid after
that
feels good to win
scott stays better as it always does
thank you
[Music]
there he is with the scotch again we
established last week that aaron the
president of your fan club said the
scotch thing is played out and there he
is doing i'm not gonna get mad at him
though if he wins ball games and keeps
balling out he drinks if he wins he
drinks if he loses he drinks if they tie
i think he's got a problem
i don't think he's got a problem
but that was a big win for them
yesterday and again they just find ways
to win a football game i mean the fact
that they're sitting there is a number
two team in the nfc playoff picture
right now to me is is amazing because
they have laws it seems like but yet
they just continue to find ways and uh
that's that speaks to rogers and lefleur
and their management of the game and
just playing the game the right way i
spoke to matt lafleur after the game
yeah let me let me go ahead and and do
the first superlative of the week yeah
go ahead all right uh this is called the
full trust award and baltimore's big
trust right in green bay it's full trust
because the audible thing that was a
thing in june because both aaron rodgers
and matt lafleur decided to talk about
it on the record right to mike silver
who knows how to stoke something into a
bigger issue than maybe it is because he
knows it's good for business and he acts
like what did i do i mean that's how the
game is played sometimes
now 15 games in
matt laflore made it clear aaron rodgers
has full and complete license to do
whatever he wants he said i have full
trust in aaron rodgers and he pointed to
fourth and four from the chicago 29
score 0-0
matt le floor call to play that would
have just gotten the first down
continued the drive aaron rodgers saw
something that he liked right he
switched to it threw the ball in the end
zone devonte adam scores yes seven
nothing right there and leflore wouldn't
have any problem with if it didn't work
the bottom line is whatever aaron sees
if he believes in it he's got the
license to do it and that is a far cry
from the offense it was very regimented
yes you have very limited discretion
right rogers has the keys full
discretion he can do whatever he wants
full trust and it works yeah they were
eleven and three yeah i mean lefleur's
he proved this all wrong whether he was
worthy for the job whether he could
handle the locker room whether he could
handle uh aaron rodgers all the things
we questioned maybe late in the spring
compare him with freddie kitchens well
right kitchen's bumbled his way through
his first year sure lafleur it's been
it's been really i mean look you're not
gonna win them all but but they've won
11. it's been professional and sharp and
the games that they've lost yeah okay
they lost the chargers and 49ers got
dominated in those games they bounced
right back didn't really bat an eye you
know loss of the eagles in a game they
could have won so they i mean they had
the ball in the one yard line in the
last play of the game um but i do you
know i you know good for you because
matt lafleur does deserve a lot of
credit and i mean he's just been very
honest and open about it and he's just a
very approachable guy that way obviously
a good communicator and uh you could see
that rogers has a real respect for him
as the way they interact coming off the
sidelines and and you're right that one
play that was huge that was that was
really one of the big moments of the
football game got green bay in the power
position early on and they kind of held
on from that point on and we gave rogers
credit look by by taking it all public
yeah he won
and he knew what was going to work right
and it's worked and the laflora's credit
he went with it yeah and here they are
and if lafleur could be coach of the
year to pay if they end up with a buy le
floor's got to get consideration without
a doubt he needs to be in that
conversation with mike tomlin mcdermott
shanahan yes he's right there john
harbaugh i think that's that's probably
the list for me right there all those
guys but uh yeah truly a phenomenal job
by him uh i
uh i'm going rodney dangerfield here the
rodney dangerfield all right that's what
is my superlative can i get a little
respect over here okay hey can i get a
little respect over here and you know i
don't know
i get no respect all right well could i
get a little respect i'm bringing some
jersey attitude into it all right and
that goes to the buffalo bills i mean
holy crap we're 40 minutes in they had
played a good game on sunday night
football last night they want a great
game to watch here we are 40 minutes in
on our network we haven't talked about
them yet i don't understand that yes got
to give the bills respect their defense
the way it played some big turnovers
interceptions down 10-7 tridavius white
getting that big interception where he
turns it down the sideline josh allen
can we give him some respect somebody
again i you know you know i like josh
allen uh and i i don't hide it but there
we are they're 10-4 and i'm just saying
that baker mayfield was 10-4
or
sam darnold was 10-4 oh man that would
be the start of the show and every show
there is oh are they the greatest thing
since sliced bread but josh allen and
the buffalo bills and sean mcdermott do
it and we just go
we'll talk about them some point in the
two-hour show why do we say the greatest
thing since sliced bread as if sliced
bread is really that big of a deal it
must have been at some point it must
have been a big deal at some point like
like i mean but what kind of innovation
is it a loaf of bread that is in one
chunk versus a pre-sliced loaf like how
is that so great i can think of far
greater innovation anyway i don't know
you're right that's deep thoughts by
mike florian we'll have a segment but
you're right though you're right and i
think the thing is
that the
the bills
like what star star power is that just i
don't know what it is all those years
without the playoffs all those years
where they kind of teased us and made us
think they were going to be a good team
and it fell apart maybe this idea that
the patriots are still the patriots and
whatever they do it isn't going to
matter they get their chance this
weekend they still go in the division
yes they do and they get a chance to
beat the paid that that will be
saturday's middle game the tr the triple
header is great is that a middle game
thanksgiving seriously you know bucks
and texans in tampa bay
yeah and then mike tarico is going to be
working bills at patriots and then the
nightcap is rams at 49ers it's a great
day it's a better slate than it was on
thanksgiving you're right it is this is
three really quality football games on
network if you don't have an nfl network
because they're all they're all on there
yeah but i do i mean just you know again
they are ten and four and they're doing
some really good things and that was a
big win against a team that always shows
up on prime time uh and it was a big win
for the buffalo bills and sean mcdermott
and their franchise who haven't been in
that spot in a long long time my next
one is the look what i found award
because the minnesota vikings
where dalvin cook well we got to fit
them in here i wanted to go with them
next but yeah seven turnovers i mean
kirk cousins was not spectacular dalvin
cook exits and who knows when he's gonna
be able to play again they didn't have
alexander madison who missed the game
with an ankle injury but seven turnovers
the vikings didn't nearly get enough
points off of those turnovers but you're
never gonna lose when the opposing team
unless you give up five six seven or
eight when you have seven turnovers
you're gonna win the game and they had
80 to 90 percent
vikings fans at that chargers 27 000
seat soccer stadium their next to last
game in that venue before they have 80
to 90 percent visiting of uh fans at
a much larger stadium that's the thing
people think it's going to get better
when the chargers move to the new
stadium no there's just going to be more
people there who are not rooting for the
chargers well yeah if they don't do
something drastic to get some different
star power on their team you're exactly
right
this game i mean first off there's a
shot if you're watching on tv the
vikings fans were there strong um i i
mean
your team wasn't impressive yesterday my
team your team the vikings but i mean
the chargers are just unreal other than
last year this is what we've been
watching from the chargers for the last
five years i mean this is what they do
i've never seen anything like it they're
going in to take the lead at halftime
they're in field goal territory you're
thinking they might score a touchdown
and go in 17 to 12 here they've kind of
controlled the first half strip sack
fumble touchdown vikings and all of a
sudden you go holy cow it's 1910. i mean
melvin gordon starting off the both
halves with fumbles i mean just one turn
of philip rivers dumb interceptions dumb
fumbles
it's it's unbelievable what they do but
uh your vikings took advantage of it and
got the victory it went from ten to nine
chargers to thirty nine to ten victor
that's 30 unanswered points and one last
thing and you know i'm reluctant to say
this yeah we're always trying to spot
the potential surprise firing two weeks
from now right
keep an eye on anthony lynn yeah man
sources close to me tell me keep an eye
on anthony lynn he could be in grave
danger and man i just i don't have to go
i'm having four last that's right i hope
that's not the case because that that
should not be you know again
not saying it's a done deal yeah i hear
you i'm just saying that's the one that
people are watching as the one that we
would look at as a surprise now
obviously the more we talk about less of
a surprise it'll be right but that's one
that that hit me yesterday from somebody
i i trust immensely
i mean listen if this isn't just for
mistakes specifically by the quarterback
in general and i don't mean to bang on a
guy who's a borderline hall of famer in
phillip rivers but i mean he just had
some huge mistakes and huge moments
that's a thick border if he's a
borderline hall of famer that's a thick
bowl yeah okay you're right maybe he's
not nfl legend i mean but i mean he
plays good better and just like solid in
a few clutch moments during the year i
mean they're sitting here still like in
the playoff conversation but instead
they're five and nine it's a disaster um
all right i gotta give the uh the double
double award okay the double double to
the the patriots their dbs i talked
about this a little bit on sunday night
football last night but they were the
difference in the football game you know
yesterday it's one of the best units in
football as we all know the new england
patriots they're secondary their corner
play
i mean that's been the magic to that
team this year and to a guy that does
not get enough respect either stefan
gilmore i mean i i think stephon gilmore
has solidifies himself as the defensive
player of the year yesterday that's what
he deserves you know again every year we
look for a team to go oh the best team
well somebody must be the mvp candidate
off their team stefan gilmore deserves
to be in the mvp conversation i mean
they are who they are because of him and
his talents in a lot of ways they play
through the defense he's the best player
on the defense he's arguably one of the
best defensive players in the league his
two interceptions were huge the bengals
were sitting there hanging around kind
of a thorn in their side he got an
interception another interception picked
six and gonna give jc jackson some
credit too because he got two
interceptions as well um but uh you know
the offense was not special again in new
england that game was won by their
defense they blew the bengals out but it
would not have happened if it weren't
for stefan gilmore and the secondary you
know shaq barrett's got 16 and a half
sacks and leads the nfl it's hard to
make a case for him to be defensive
player of the year though i know team's
not a playoff team you don't think
defense when you think of the bucks you
think jameis wins right right no i know
and you know aaron donald of course
deserves to be in the conversation he's
still you know arguably the best
defensive player in the league but you
know we're talking about the best that
they they're not going to make the
playoffs either no they're not and we're
talking about the best team you know one
of the best defenses in football one of
the best pass defenses we've seen in a
while and gilmore is the focal point of
that he deserves to be that guy this
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports